emmanuel macron and the french
government are again
under pressure this time it's over the
initial response
to the covid 19 crisis the backlash has
already seen several lawsuits and even a
parliamentary inquiry
now the leader of the national rally
marine le pen
has waded in to the debate
i realize that the new government is in
process of repeating more or less the
same mistakes as the previous one
even though dozens of other countries
are seeing a substantial increase in
coronavirus cases
and that on our territory hospitals are
reporting intensive care admissions
for people coming or returning from
abroad
in this book the coronavirus black book
from fiasco to abyss
the party claims president macron and
his government misled the public during
the pandemic
many issues have been raised first
there's the wearing of face masks it
points out that when the lockdown was
announced
stocks of masks were taken over by the
government
with pharmacies forbidden from selling
them to the general public
now of course wearing a face mask is
obligatory
in enclosed public spaces
the tragedy of this crisis is that we're
in a country with the highest taxation
in the world
where the fiscal bill is the highest on
the planet and where at the same time
we've lacked fabric masks and obviously
many french people have not understood
this
so it is a question of where the money
is going where the french people's money
is going
the book jumps on european leaders for
allowing
free movement in the block to continue
despite the fact that there were warning
signs
the national rally also takes a swipe at
issues such as
those in suburban areas in france and
accuses the justice system here of being
too
lacks because it released prisoners
during
the crisis there are a whole series of
statements made by the government and
ministers that
frankly were just nonsense and they were
doing
what western governments have developed
a habit of doing was just saying what
suited the moment in order to get over a
difficulty
it is inevitable that uh marine le pen
and other politicians will criticize the
government because their performance has
been
lamentable they're not the only ones i
mean if you look at the british
government they haven't done any better
but the french actually i have to say
from my observation internationally
have probably performed worse than
anybody official data suggests that more
than 30
000 people who tested positive for ko
fit 19
has so far died in total more than 185
000 cases of the virus have been
registered the french
government has been battling against
covet 19.
it launched a strict lockdown that
lasted nearly two months
constructed military hospitals to deal
with patient overflow
and it injected billions of euros into
aiding businesses
and those who found themselves out of
work as a result of the pandemic
but despite its efforts opinion polls
have not
been favorable there are even claims
that frontline health workers were not
given
enough protective equipment we are very
very angry because there's been a
shortage of staff for years already
and this pandemic has created an even
bigger problem
promises were made but in fact they
haven't been kept we still have a lack
of beds
and that is just getting worse i think
that we weren't ready for this
we haven't been protected enough we have
a shortage of equipment and that's why
we failed those who got infected
marine le pen is clearly staking her
claim
to run in france's next presidential
election in
2022 however many of the accusations
and the complaints in this book do
reflect
real concerns that are felt by the
french public
joel diebinski rt paris
you